foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman is here
what it is oh man coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
joined by Zach Bush MD a triple board
certified physician who specializes in
Internal Medicine endocrinology and
hospice care today we're speaking with
Dr Bush about a topic that many people
are scared to death to discuss we're
talking about simplifying death you can
check out the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 362 where we and Dr
Bush answer four times the questions and
we dive deep into several simple living
segments that full private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
suck Alabama where you want to start
today let's start with a question from
Sarah in Savannah Georgia
my name is Sarah and I'm a patreon
supporter from Savannah Georgia I was
calling to ask Dr Bush if he might be
able to give some sort of insight into
how those that are in the active dying
process are seemingly effortlessly able
to let go of possessions of regrets fear
just really anything that keeps them
from being in the present moment I've
been a caregiver for over 20 years and
have had the honor of caring for those
who have passed and I am just in awe of
how they are able to release everything
and just be in that present moment and
if possible I would love to learn that
skill
Zach I'm reminded of the title of our
our last Netflix film was called less is
now which is a play on the miese van der
rohe less is more but the thing we
wanted to convey there is it's
impossible to sort of cling to the now
although we always try the clinging
always happens with the the past or
we're cling to some idealized version of
the future and I'm reminded of one of my
favorite philosophers a guy named Kapil
Gupta and he said I wish everyone would
have a near-death experience every six
months so they would know what it's like
to truly live and so if we're talking to
Sarah here about that living in the
moment being present quite often those
near-death experiences or the the period
where you are near death allows us to
finally live for the first time in our
lives it's so true yeah the process of
dying biologically is an exciting
letting go of a huge Memory Bank of
emotional baggage and so you were
talking about clinging to the experience
of now we do that all the time it takes
a lot of energy obviously to cling to
something and I think the ones that we
do it most often with are the polar
extremes we cling to fear and we cling
to love and we try to hold on to both of
those as soon as they occur because they
justify the one the fear justify the way
that we actually deep down
feel and so a new stimulus of fear comes
in and we grab onto it because it
justifies all the things that we've been
feeling it's like oh my goodness thank
God I'm afraid of this external thing
when in fact we're probably afraid of
something much more internal a
disconnect within ourselves on the other
side of the equation you experience that
love stimulus you find that vibration of
love for a moment you're like oh my God
this is what I can't get myself this is
this is what I've been needing and we
cling to that of course as soon as you
grab on to either of those they become
Elusive and they start to slip through
your hands fear will often Bloom into
paranoia and once it's grabbed onto you
and so that that initial stimulus of
kind of fight or flight suddenly moves
to to a fear of isolation and
everything's against me and that kind of
Separation you know event happens when
you grab onto love it quickly transforms
into duty or expectation
and so we do these things all the time
and in the effort of clinging to to the
moment we often find ourselves out of
energy to keep clinging and so what we
often do is bury those things within us
and so it takes less energy I think to
bury something within us so we bury our
fears we bury a memory of love and we
try to remember those things and you
know access those at will
unfortunately in the process of burying
and emotion is actually a very
physiologic reality and we tend to put
specific emotions in specific parts of
our body Chinese medicine for 4 000
years has been working on detailing out
what this this map of the body's
emotional history looks like and
examples of the base of the lungs is
where we store unprocessed grief uh the
spleen is where we process worry and
that is often specific to our inability
to care for others the kidneys are where
we kind of store our maternal stress of
not able to Nest or take care of those
around us appropriately our low back is
where we carry Financial stress
especially if it's Financial stress
around our immediate home or family so
low back pain is an element or an
expression of financial stress or the
inability to care for those in your nest
and so those things have been played out
and so what are callers referring to
here is in witnessing somebody in the
dying process they suddenly start
letting go of these buried phenomena
that have kept them
in a fearful slash loved prived State uh
over their their lifetime and they've
manifested all kinds of dis-ease and
pain fatigue disorders diseases in that
manifestation of all this buried
treasure within them it seems and the
cool thing about biologic death is
what's happening is you're losing the
water structure within the cells and so
as cells lose their Vitality they start
to lose the crystalline structure and
that crystalline water structure inside
your cells is the hard drive it is the
memory bank of all of your stored stuff
and so as we start to die we start
dissolving at that water crystal level
and we start having to let go we can't
any longer hold on to or keep buried
these things
and so you go to the therapist in your
health and you've got all this
crystalline memory of all that you've
buried you've got to go through a
process but when you're biologically
dying you don't have to process those
they're simply slipping out of your
reality and so that's what the caller is
witnessing is she's witnessing somebody
slipping out of the entire memory of
their emotional traumatic
path and starting to be alive and I
really have seen that over and over
again where you will hear crystalline
truth crystalline Beauty coming out of
the mouths of people dying because for
the first time they see life for what it
is which is constantly beautiful which
is constantly in a state of expression
of energy and is a manifestation of
light and they can see that suddenly
because they've had to let go of all of
the beliefs that have kept them
disconnected from that reality and we
get there before we know we have to go
I'm excited for that question I think
that that's exactly what I've put my
last you know 12 years into and a lot of
it came down to this experience on
hospice so when I was an associate
medical director for a hospice
organization in Virginia we were seeing
80 admissions to my service every week
of people that were given less than six
months to live but in the US were very
hesitant to put people on hospice
because we always want people to have
hope and we we hate that discussion of
like you know what we've done everything
your body is dying we would like to give
you the opportunity to live for quality
instead of quantity of life and let's
just make you comfortable that's a very
hard conversation for us to have for
some reason in the Western Medical thing
I think has to do with the fear of death
it feels like a failure as a physician
to say you know what we we failed we
didn't Stave death off you know and so
we we've put ourselves we've pitted
ourselves against death as if there was
some sort of metric for success or
failure
and in that journey I think that what we
end up seeing is about you know
10 to 15 percent of people admitted a
hospice get discharged from hospice
because they suddenly start to live
and what tends to happen is we
discontinue the medications and all of
the therapies and shockingly when you
stop you know 13 medications six of
which have essentially active qualities
to them and you let that brain Clear its
pharmaceutical
chaos it can certainly turn back on and
that person suddenly gets the spark of
life back and it's really biology
doesn't drive death it's the spark of
curiosity the spark of creativity that
drives a lifespan and so if you if you
allow people to reconnect their
curiosity and their creativity they can
suddenly you know all the organ systems
start coming back online six months
later they have to be discharged from
hospice because they're not dying fast
enough and then three years later they
die of something else and you know
peacefully in their bed or whatever you
know so so the exciting thing is to
answer your question is in that moment
of starting to be alive you don't have
to die and so death is an opportunity
for us as a species to come into a state
of Vitality that just doesn't tend to
invite itself in our current social
constructs our current behavioral
patterns are keeping us from this life
within the body and so sometimes it's
the imitation of death that gives us the
opportunity to live
an amazingly I think that's where we're
at as a species we can see our own
hospice moment now we are we have a
pending Extinction and we can see it and
we can scientifically predict it's 80
100 years out that's a pretty short
lifespan for a species so we're on our
hospice moment so can we do what you
just asked can we start to live do are
we going to make the decision to live by
a vital life or we can continue to drug
ourselves into
a stupid state of death is is there like
a a practice or routine or something
that can help us release the
crystallization that you were talking
about because like
if I was to answer Sarah's question I
would have been like oh you know for me
meditation helps me live in the moment
and it's it's all up here and what I
hear you saying is it's mostly not up
here it's kind of stored in other areas
is there is there a process of letting
that crystallization go or yeah yes yeah
you're talking about detoxing though
yeah the memory bank basically how do we
detox the memory bank of the human body
from these emotions there's a whole host
of avenues into this there's not one
prescription at all
um I'd find that if if I was going to
have to say one thing it would simply be
nature yeah
I didn't even know about ketamine
treatments until moving to La anyway
yeah I love that I love the answer of
nature that's that's great man that's
how that's how nature is spelled in last
year yeah
[Laughter]
it's also like the six letter word for
God yeah but um anyway so you know the
the ketamine you know experience is
ultimately one anybody doing any plant
medicine tends to come back with a story
of like oh my God I saw nature and I was
one with it yeah you know and so whether
you need the plant medicine to show you
smack you upside the head and be like
dude idiot you're from me yeah or you
simply just go out in nature and spend
three days backpacking in the wilderness
or surfing or whatever it is that's
gonna float your boat out there the
detox happens almost immediately because
to stay in the vibrational memory of
your traumatic emotional past you cannot
be present and a tree refuses to let you
be anywhere but right now yeah and so my
favorite pastime I think if you know in
that nature experience if you're just
feeling completely overwhelmed with life
if you're feeling so heavy with the
emotional burden that you're currently
carrying lay down on your back and
ideally like mid morning like 10 a.m or
mid afternoon lay down on your back
under a tree and look up through the
branches and leaf patterns out of sky
with you know combination of blue sky
and white clouds moving by
and feel the tree and the patterns of
light that occur through those branches
the way that they create these fractals
and these Quantum kind of relationships
to the light behind them
are a neurologic reprogramming deep
within the body and the body is going to
start to remember an original math
and that's really what nature does it's
oh it's basically a tuning fork that's
humming these original mathematical
frequencies and for that we remember who
we are and for that we remember the
original math of your liver of your
lungs of your spleen and your organ
system can start to let go tune out the
the memorial of of your emotional
reality and come into this present
moment
and at this time of death the caller was
talking about you're in this
extraordinary transition where you're
moving from a finite biologic expression
of an infinite being okay it's the
infinite being some people would like to
call a soul whatever you want to call it
it is a well established energetic
Center that holds a mathematical reality
for your biology to line up on it is the
the energetic template or blueprint for
the biology to respond to and so how do
you form in the womb of your mother you
follow this biologic kind of map that's
based on an energetic blueprint and we
can image the energy field we do this in
our clinic for the last 15 years we've
been Imaging the human energy field to
study how it carries its traumatic
memory and so you can see your energy
field different than your energy field
because you've stored energetic trauma
or memory in different locations of each
of your bodies and that gives you a
blueprint of what's going to happen in
the next 10 years 15 years for the next
three years in your biology and so the
energy field really is the map it is the
blueprint for which the biology is going
to follow and so death is this beautiful
experience where you are letting go of
the biologic expression of an infinite
blueprint and you're becoming infinite
again and the beauty of that infinite
being is it cannot carry your emotional
history it does not have water structure
to carry the emotion in and so that's
why you have to let go of the emotional
burden is you are literally moving back
into your infinite expression yeah and
you have no choice at that point and
that letting go is beautiful I can tell
you one thing that is has been difficult
for me is uh the clinging to what's
going to happen as soon as I'm gone I
worry about my family or what if I get
into some sort of terrible accident and
so uh very practically Sarah we have a
essay on our website it's called scared
to death of death and it's the
minimalists.com death we'll put a link
to it in the show notes but it talks
about getting together a living will
power of attorney last will and
testament uh becoming an organ donor if
you so choose and some of the benefits
of doing that to help others once you've
you've passed away but handling those
things and revisiting them occasionally
has given me a peace of mind because I
have a DNR I don't want to be
resuscitated and kept on you know
ventilators or whatever but someone else
may want that and that's totally fine
but understanding what you want so you
can have that all written down and clear
for your Physicians for your partners
for anyone else who's in your life or
your family so you're not burdening them
as well and of course coming up in a
little bit here we're going to talk
about what to do with your stuff before
you die as well Sarah I'd love to send
you a copy of our book everything that
remains Ryan wrote this book a decade
ago and it was a it was a story about
finally beginning to live in the moment
focusing on something that allowed us to
focus to actually be present because
when Ryan and I were in the corporate
world beforehand I was telling you we've
known each other since we were fat
little fifth graders and we thought the
key to our happiness was to get out of
the poverty we grew up in and then we
would be happy as soon as we started
making money and working 80 hours a week
but we were always so future oriented
that we never made time to actually live
in the moment until we started to walk
away from that and realizing like no
success isn't tomorrow it's not next
year it's not next decade it is right
now you can and by the way happiness
doesn't exist a day from now a year from
now it exists only in the present moment
so so I'm going to send you a copy of
everything that remains if you like our
podcast you'll enjoy the uh audiobook
version or if you want the book book or
the ebook version we'll send those to
you as well but Ryan in the meantime
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions your comments to
937-202-4654 Professor Sean get your
buzzer ready so during the lightning
round Zach this is where we and our
guests do our best to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response but not really Sean
puts a minute on the clock for us and we
just wander on a bit and he tweezes out
something pithy to put in the show notes
so people can share our minimal maxims
on social media you can find all of
those minimal maxims in the show notes
the minimalists.com
podcast it looks like Jerry has a
question for us I am not suicidal but I
don't want to live to be 90 or 100
Medical Aid and dying is only available
to those who are terminally ill so is
there another legal and ethical option
for me to choose when I'm ready to go so
I'm going to start this one off if you
want to throw 60 seconds on the clock
for me I'm actually going to stay steal
a quote from Zach and hopefully he can
use some of my time to elaborate on it I
heard you say death is the Ultimate
Upgrade
and that's when I knew I wanted to have
you on the podcast my wife introduced me
to your work and then I just thought I
went down this rabbit hole and I heard
because I went through a lot of these
sort of health problems in my own life
and was contemplating my own mortality
and then I heard you say death is the
Ultimate Upgrade can you elaborate on
that yeah you're taking it from the
finite to the infinite and you know
that's the Ultimate Upgrade is you are
right now a finite particle expression
of an Infinite Source an infinite being
and that finite reality is beautiful and
that's why we pick the finite journey is
because we get to witness Beauty in a
unique way what is the purpose of
humanity to witness Beauty through the
five senses through our experience of
social connectivity and so so through
this hyper intelligence of a community
of society and empowered by our five
senses and and our the analytical mind
we get to be witness to Beauty on a
level that just can't be done in the
infinite realm and so we choose a finite
life I'm so that we can see the beauty
of nature so that we can see the beauty
of the fabric of reality and then we
will go into this upgraded state of
vibration where we know all things we
have no perception of there's the coffee
cup and the steam coming off it because
you are the steam you are the coffee you
are the thing because you are vibration
and so you're going to lose the temporal
perspective as soon as you shift into
this upgraded state of the infinite
I can't imagine in my finite being what
it feels like to be infinite except that
in these little Parts where I become the
storm where I become the one that will
die on his pillow tonight I get to feel
this little
little sound it's a little vibration
sounds like a tone almost in my
beingness
that is so child pure it is so without
expectation
if you know Zach Bush he's terrible
short answers
oh yes death is the Ultimate Upgrade
Ryan Let's uh you got something pithy
for us yeah uh my pit the answer is the
experience of Life cannot exist without
the looming promise of death and I have
just recently been able to get to this
place of not just appreciating my life
but appreciating the deaths that will
come eventually
and I'm telling I'm telling you like
when you can get to a place where you
can say thank you life
thank you death thank you life thank you
death I fear deaths so little these days
because I can appreciate both of those
things and what I'll say you know to to
this this answer of or this question of
how do I off myself at 90 years old is
appreciate the life you have you have no
idea how you're going to feel at 90. you
have no idea so just appreciate the life
while you have it and find a way to
appreciate the death that will come we
were talking about earlier today that
life confers death right and
understanding that enables us to accept
both as as though they are the same
thing yeah PK you got anything pithy for
us oh man
all right I have here life and death are
best taken one day at a time I think if
you try too hard to pre make strong
predictions about a future moment you'll
psych yourself out of the present moment
which is where all of your power your
wisdom and your creativity is but not
only that when you say something like
hey I know for sure I don't want to be
around when I'm 90 you're not only
presupposing that you'll actually be in
a position to make that choice
right like maybe you really want to do
the 50s and 60s and the 70s but not the
90s who says you get to do the 50s 60s
and 70s so you not only presuppose that
you have the power to make that choice
but you are also attaching yourself to
an idea about the future that's based on
someone who knows nothing about what
it's like to be 90. maybe you can be the
person to reinvent people's
understanding of how beautiful life at
90 can be so for me I would say instead
of trying to figure out when I need to
die I would try to figure out how to
live in such a way so that when I do die
the impact that I leave is
inextinguishable
let's check in with our patreon live
stream real quick I'm Alabama is anyone
asking some questions for Dr Zach Bush
while we have him here yes we have a
question from Ella she said my mom died
a few weeks ago and she's given us a few
signs that she is on the other side but
I feel like I'm depressed even though I
know only her physical body has died do
people who believe in life after death
grieve differently for their loved ones
yeah I would also just welcome you to
let go of the concept of depression now
it's an overused word overused concept
and it's often supplant something much
more real which is in the word you did
use which is grief there so you're
experiencing grief right now and there's
many layers to it and it's beautiful in
the way in which grief unfolds in the
physiology and so I would invite you to
feel everything that you are feeling
without labeling in and and move into
that sensation of what it feels like for
your mother to transition out of the
body and regardless of your belief of
what's happening on that other side you
experiencing the feelings and
acknowledging them and then reflecting
on what beauty your mother had in your
life that would have triggered that
emotion is your journey into a really
free state with your mother's passing
Wow Let's do one more from the live
stream we have another question from
Kathy how do I emotionally prepare
myself for my father's death when we
finally have a wonderful relationship
again
oh wow it sounds like that's one of
those good problems right because Ryan I
know that you've gone through quite a
few issues with your father
and imagine
reconciling that just to know now you're
going to lose the person I think it's a
you you're struggling because oh I
finally got the thing that I wanted kind
of like us in the corporate world you
when you get everything you thought you
wanted just to realize that maybe
everything you ever wanted you can't
simply hold on to or maybe the
everything you ever wanted isn't
actually what you wanted at all
mm-hmm yeah I think that's that's
ultimately the the story there it's it's
that thing that we just started the
podcast with is we hold on to fear and
we hold on to love you're experiencing
love right now you're trying to hold on
to this thing uh that you're
experiencing with your father and it's
it's worthwhile to acknowledge that the
vibration that you're feeling from your
father is an infinite vibration it is
perhaps the fabric of of the reality
that we live in which is beauty when
perceived creates the experience of love
you're seeing the beauty in your father
right now so you're having the
experience of love and so what I would
encourage you to do is start to find
your father in everything around you and
go to the park with your father go out
to dinner with your father share a meal
with your father find your father in the
in the glass of wine or in the steak or
in the vegetables whatever he's eating
find your father in the way in which he
expresses himself within this finite
reality and you'll start to see your
father everywhere and you'll realize
you're not actually in love with a
person you're in love with the beauty
that you see in this person that is a
finite expression of infinite Beauty
around you and so the love that we
experience with one another is truly
unconditional it is not conditional on
how long they live or whether they're
here with us in the body or not in the
body is truly unconditional state of
being witness to beauty and so condition
yourself to witness Beauty and to
recognize it quickly and acknowledge its
sacredness its sanctity its vibrational
force and the feeling of love that you
get when you see the beauty and your
your father will become ever ever
present with you
ladies and gentlemen Dr Zach Bush yes oh
my goodness I want to acknowledge you
for the work that you do and say we're
really grateful for having you here on
the podcast today how can our listeners
there are many of them how can they best
support you in the work you're doing and
find out more about you
and best support me by letting go of all
the narratives that make people say that
what I the future that I want to occur
is impossible we need to let go of all
of those so help me surrender all the
narratives in the public uh surrender
our commitment to our stories of
politics is impossible social change is
impossible healing of socialism trauma
and emotional trauma is impossible let
go of the impossible and become possible
with me for this future that we could
share and manifest together you can find
me at my educational site zackbushmd.com
the global health education Summit has a
big deep dive on a lot of different
topics we have a two-hour panel on death
and rebirth and that might be a
continuation of this journey you've had
today I've got two death doulas on with
that show if you haven't heard of a
death Doula it's an expert in in helping
a family and a loved one transition and
so get some insights there we also have
a neurosurgeon on there that talks about
these near-death experiences and the
perspectives of people when they're
brain dead in the operating room and all
of the things they witness and see in
these brain dead States and come back to
tell him about and so it's a powerful
Journey there there's a bunch of other
topics we cover the virome and
autoimmune stuff and autism and all
kinds of different subjects there so
Global health education and the
knowledge Pages Zach bushmd.com for our
basic science work around the interface
of soil and human health and the
supplements that are designed to embody
this communication network of the biome
its intelligence of nature.com if you're
really in need of a care team around you
or a journey yourself into this Freedom
that we're talking about on how to
become alive we've got an eight-week
program called journey of intrinsic
Health that's at the same.com Journey of
intrinsichealth.com it's an eight-week
Journey where you're paired with a coach
where you can go through group coaching
too which is a very powerful way to be
witnessed transformation and others with
you and as six or eight people go
through this journey together
and the journey is really finding you
into your own Freedom so that you can
start to become that alive state that
vibrational state that we're expressing
this one so you can keep looking for
many other ones you can follow me on
social media if you want but I encourage
you to really engage the websites
because ultimately Community is where
we're at uh journey of intrinsic Health
actually has an app that we've created a
community app and so there's ways in
which user groups are being spawned
after the eight weeks people are
creating their own user groups in
communities and around special interests
and things like that to create the
future that we all want we'll put links
to everything you just talked about in
the show notes you can find all of those
at the minimalists.com podcast in
Alabama we got a bunch more to talk
about on the private podcast today we're
going to do a home tour Ryan and I will
argue about something I'm sure
no we won't yes we will
you're gonna have to speak about Ryan's
death later
so we got a lot more to talk about from
Alabama what do you got for us first
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hey everyone my name is
Colleen and I'm from Mechanicsburg
Pennsylvania I'm reflecting on the
episode on kids stuff and I thought that
I would share a tip that has allowed me
to keep my sanity as an expecting mother
and having to be dressed every single
day of my life about two years ago I've
transitioned to a minimalist wardrobe
that included six of the same black
dress but when I selected the dress I
had in the back of my mind that it would
be nice if since we were eventually
going to be adding another child to the
family it would grow with me so to speak
this ended up working out since honestly
the style that I liked anyway fit the
bill
um but with that said I am now seven
months pregnant and carrying larger than
expected
um and these dresses still are my main
wardrobe staple
I feel like that the maternity clothes
money grab is something that we need to
change so this is my solution to that
problem I'm sure hoping that they
continue to fit me for the last two
months of my pregnancy but I sure am
happy to have made it
um to seven months and still able to
wear the same dress but I find if I need
something then it'll be a very small
calculated purchase
um and it'll be for a short amount of
time so I will donate those clothes once
I'm I'm finished maybe to a women's
shelter all right Joe let's return to
the public podcast for a moment we've
just wrapped up a three hour private
podcast that folks can check out over at
patreon.com the minimalist before we get
to our added value segment I'm returning
to Our Roots for this added value
segment you're going to get immense
value from this real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
we just released 20 more tickets to our
sold out Sunday Symposium that's going
on in October these Sunday Symposium
events they're in Los Angeles they're
downtown we're hanging out with y'all
we're giving out hugs a lot of hugs well
200 plus hugs uh only 200 people are
able to make it into the venue because
the venue only seats 200 people so are
these intimate events where we talk to
you not in a preachy way but to help
understand some truths that are profound
to each of us and so these are different
from our typical tour stops we meet
together it's kind of like church but
not like church at all we're not
preaching to you we're not converting
you to anything it's certainly not a
cult our very first one we had Amanda
Montel there and she she made sure we
weren't starting a cult right which was
beautiful uh we had Ella my daughter at
the last one she gave and it was her
first time on stage nine years old
nailed it there um she may start her own
cult yeah yeah I'm following her yeah me
too yeah I think she's found some truths
it's called Sunday Symposium we have
special guests we have music we have a
special time together half the tickets
are free half are paid and it's a sold
out event but we just released 20 more
free tickets you can find those right
now get there today because they will
sell out on the first day because
they're free
sundaysymposium.com if they do sell out
please please get on the wait list so we
can let you know if someone's giving up
their tickets we'll welcome you in there
we really enjoy having you there in
person there's something about these
in-person experiences TK that allows us
to communicate 8 in an intimate setting
that you can't always do in front of a
microphone
absolutely I mean just as there is the
difference between standing next to a
tree and being out in nature versus
looking at things through a screen
there's just a big difference between
having the people in the room it's no
longer doing a podcast for an audience
it's an act of co-creation that emerges
spontaneously and it's so cool it's so
fun and there's no other way to describe
it than that it's just a celebratory
dance of energy like you gotta be there
like Frank Sinatra says be there
and these are the Ryan these are the
smallest tour stops we've done in years
and because we're intentionally keeping
the small just 200 people if you do want
to buy a ticket you're welcome to do
that sundaysymposium.com that helps us
pay for the venue TK Ryan and I all lose
money on this event we make sure all the
staff is paid the venue is paid
Etc but we're trying to create this
experience for you in person if you're
anywhere in Southern California join us
October 30th or any of the future events
you can get on the wait list if it is
sold out Sunday symposium.com for our
added value this week guys you probably
saw this we're at the Green Room at
Sunday Symposium I just bought this for
our studio and I tested at my house as
well this is a CO2 meter it measures
other things as well like temperature
and barometric pressure and humidity and
and all those other things which are
interesting but I've been getting these
weird headaches for the last month and a
half and I couldn't figure out why I
think I've cracked the code because the
guest house that I live in in I usually
keep it very sealed up right I'm just
constantly breathing all the time
heavily just hyperventilating whenever
I'm by myself
that's hey don't kink shame me Ryan Hey
man whatever you're into bro this uh
we'll put a link to this particular one
of the shows I don't care if you uh get
this one or any other CO2 monitor this
one is a little bit on the pricier side
it's a couple hundred bucks but uh from
all the reviews I read it is the most
um accurate now I want to bring this
back because added value when we started
this segment way back in 2015 on the
first episode of The Mentalist podcast
it was really about hey advertisements
suck but sometimes we can talk about
actual physical Goods even as the
minimalists we can talk about physical
Goods that add value to our lives we get
that a lot by the way people are like
hey
um sensing a contradiction here you say
advertisements suck but then you talk
about things that add value to your life
isn't that the same as advertisements
perfect opportunities we are walking
contradictions minimalists are no
minimalists every human is a walking
contradiction amen now what I'll say is
this is not an advertisement
advertisement would be if this this
company which is called SFA aeronaut 4.
I have no idea who they are they're not
paying us to talk about this product and
if they did it'd be hard for me to give
an unbiased review because what if it
breaks what if it sucks what if I didn't
like it but now I have to talk about it
or when I listen to my favorite podcast
or talking about McDonald's or Coors I
want to throw up onto my device because
I'm like what are you doing you know
you're just propagating this poison
because I'm guessing you don't actually
get value from those things or even if
they do now they're being paid to talk
about it right I'm not being paid to
talk about this we'll put a link to it
in the show notes you're welcome to
check it out I don't care if you have a
CO2 meter or not here's what I realize
and I'm realizing it here in this room
you look at this if you if you're
watching the video version of this our
current CO2 level is 2100. now outdoor
air is around 400 acceptable healthy
breathable errors is below a thousand
and then it gets into the yellow range
we're High into the red range as soon as
you you get above 2000 that means the
CO2 level in the studio which when I
first came in here this morning was
about 500 great air quality yep what's
happening though Ryan there's a million
people breathing right now I told you to
stop breathing I'm wondering I'm
wondering is there a way
um can we can we bring oxygen tanks in
I'm serious bring oxygen tanks in here
and like release oxygen into the air to
count to counter this because what I
what I noticed is when we came back from
break you know we let all the air
conditioning out I'm sweating down my
back which is which is fine
um I mean it's harder for me to
concentrate but I'm wondering it's
because as soon as we close the windows
it gets right back up yeah so what we do
is we open the windows and this this
goes down because we're letting the
oxygen in the answer to the question is
I don't know if we could bring something
in that would not add noise to the
podcast I'm just talking about like when
it gets to a certain level during the
break we can just turn the oxygen on
we'll look into it maybe yeah I don't
know but here's what I noticed my sleep
is now better because all I had to do is
crack some windows and all of a sudden
when I first turned this on it was 2300
and where I lived I just opened a few
windows and within half an hour we're
back to outdoor levels and so someone a
friend of ours Jeff Sarris who's our web
developer he he was telling me about
this like oh people who are often sick
in their homes because we're trapped in
our homes all the time and we're
breathing all of the stale air which
made sense to me intuitively I don't
know why I never thought about this
before why haven't I ever thought about
the level of CO2 that is in my home is
it a dangerous level is it safe well now
I know and I can bring this around
anywhere I put it in the Green Room our
Green Room was fine I could put it here
in the studio studio is fine for a while
until we're all in here for three hours
breathing in or breathing out all the
CO2 another thing you can do is adding
plants to your home that will obviously
take in the CO2 and allow you to breathe
in more oxygen we need plants in the
studio there you go I hear I hear you're
an industry plant
hey so right now windows are closed the
air is off what if we kept the windows
closed we turn the air conditioning on
what would happen to those CO2 levels it
would improve slightly but not nearly as
much as you just opened up the windows
right because because we're letting some
out but just not enough yeah you're not
gonna be getting enough fresh air and so
you want that outdoor air and you can do
it real easy I mean and it's free too
just simply open up your windows all of
a sudden you're now breathing oxygen so
if you're dealing with headaches or any
sort of chronic illness from being
trapped inside an office or whatever
getting a CO2 meter to just figure out
what is the CO2 level of where I spend
most of my time it could be your desk it
could be in your home it could be in
your garage it could be in your car so I
think I brought in the car on the way
down I realized I don't want to recycle
the air in my car this was off the
charts as soon as I hit that button that
it's brought in the air from the outside
this went back down to outdoor levels
immediately I did not take for granted
that like
I'm not that sensitive to things like I
really appreciate that
Josh is like oh it's 2100 it could be
2100 or 500 and I feel the same and yeah
and I uh yeah I just I just don't I
don't want to take that for granted that
I'm because I'm sure my body will
eventually stop processing things the
way it processes
um but yeah I just yeah and I could also
eat a bucket of nails and like digest
that just fine yes but it could happen
for lunch actually oh my gosh
what could happen here though is it
could be contributing long term to some
sort of chronic illness that you're not
experiencing acutely right now because
it's the build up over time yeah and so
yes I might be more sensitive than you
but in a way I'm simply the canary in
the coal mine and there is danger right
around the corner for you just like
everyone else like if you don't have any
Oxygen at some level you're going to die
Ryan speaking of I need to wrap this up
because I need to breathe some oxygen
let's play you out with a song This one
is called
death With Dignity it's from my favorite
Sufjan Stevens album he's one of my
favorite artists this album is called
Carrie and Lowell and the song is about
forgiving so that you can let go even
when you want to cling
one of my favorite lyrics from the song
is I forgive you mother I can hear you
and I long to be near you but every road
leads to an end that's awesome and so as
we end this episode thank you so much to
Dr Zach Bush for joining us you can
check him out we'll put a link to
everything that he's working on in the
show notes by the way TK we got a bunch
more surprise questions on the private
podcast this week like how can we avoid
burdening our loved ones with our
leftover stuff when we die
does Dr Bush believe that we have souls
that exit our body when we die
what are 12 things the minimalists own
that aren't very minimalist plus a
million more questions for Dr Zach Bush
and the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that Alabama tell them what to
do check out the minimalist private
podcast visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of Live
Events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com the
minimalists if you have a question or
listener tip for our podcast give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalist.com follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
and to get our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list at
the minimum dot com thank you Alabama
that is our show for today on behalf of
Ryan Nicodemus TK Coleman Alabama
podcast Sean Jordan no more Professor
Sean social justice Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team I'm Joshua
Fields Wilburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it